baisse de moyens dédiés à la prévention
spécialisée abandon du projet de
réhabilitation du collège mais surtout
fermeture de la pmi de magny les hameaux
pour la municipalité les décisions du
conseil départemental ne passe pas pour
protester contre ces choix plus de 150
personnes ont manifesté avec les élus
samedi dernier aujourd'hui la
collectivité qui est le département
participe à la désertification de notre
commune
on nous parle de la fermeture définitive
qui m'a été annoncée la semaine dernière
par un vice président du conseil
départemental de notre de notre pmi en
nous expliquant que vous comprenez ça
sera mieux dans un plus grand centre
mais à 15 km vous aurez beaucoup plus de
possibilités là bas mais par contre pour
y aller faire ses 15 km aujourd'hui
aucune solution contre l' asphyxie
c'était le mot d'ordre de cette marche
également pointé du doigt par le maire
le rapprochement entre le département
des hauts-de-seine et des yvelines aux
dépens des communes rurales on va soi
disant se marier avec avec l'aude scène
ça n'apportera rien aux services de
proximité alors que le coeur des
responsabilités d'un département
c'est l'action sociale c'est l'enfance
c'est des collèges et tout ça
aujourd'hui c'est tout ce que ne fait
plus le département avec vernon ma fille
qui va rentrer au collège en sixième en
septembre vous avez vu le collège c'est
pas du luxe il nous avait programmé les
travaux qu'ils annulent et je trouve ça
dommage
aujourd'hui on voit bien que les
communes en plus en plus de difficultés
pour financer certains projets qui leur
tiennent à coeur et qui peuvent
bénéficier au plus grand nombre
les élus ne compte pas s'arrêter là et
veulent poursuivre la mobilisation
de son côté l'opposition explique ce
désengagement du conseil départemental
par les baisses de dotations de l'état
avec 196 millions d'euros en moins les
yvelines serait le département le plus
touché de france